bonsoir monsieur beaudry bonsoir
monsieur fillion vous avez dit
aujourd'hui qu'il est probable qu'on
doive amener le taux directeur au delà
du taux neutre hier dans la décision de
la banque ont parlé d' agir avec plus de
force ça veut dire quoi exactement
il faut bien remettre en contexte cela
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
dans l'économie en particulièrement on
est en situation ou que l'inflation
continue à augmenter on est dans une
situation que le marché du travail
surchauffe et on a l'impression que les
gens commencent à penser que peut-être
cette inflation va rester pour longtemps
donc nous à la banque du canada notre
mandat c'est de ramener l'inflation à 2
% donc on regarde où il faut aller de ce
sens là qu'est ce qu'on avait dit
auparavant qu'on ars à céret d'amener le
taux d'intérêt au tourneur qui est
quelque part on estime en 2 et 3% et
maintenant avec les nouvelles aspects on
se dit probablement il va falloir être
dans le haut de cette fourchette là on
verra asseyez de déterminer en ce moment
mais on regarde les éléments en main par
an mais c'est certain qu'on pense qu'on
va être il faut aller vers le haut de la
fourchette de 2 à 3% alors le haut de la
fourchette de 2 à 3% c'est donc 3%
aujourd'hui on est à 1,5 donc qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il y aura plusieurs
hausses de taux d'intérêt pour se rendre
jusqu'à 3% d'ici la fin de l'année mais
premièrement j'ai pas dit que
nécessairement pouvoir à 3 pour ça on va
aller chaque décision on prend les
données de l'économie on regarde comment
que l'économie réagit on ne nous nous
décisions passées donc on n'est jamais
sûr le côté automatique c'est pas comme
l'idée qu'on va aller nécessairement à 3
on donne un peu une idée ou à peu près
qu'on essaye de se diriger et à ce
moment là il va falloir penser à mesure
que ça arrive on voudrait y arriver
assez rapidement donc probablement ça
veut dire un ensemble de
une série d'augmentations taux d'intérêt
sur les projets les prochains mois
est ce que ça veut dire une hausse de
taux par exemple de 75 points de base
est-ce que ça fait partie des scénarios
possibles c'est dans le possible c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on ait décidé de
fermer on voit le considérer si c'est
nécessaire encore là ça dépend un peu de
développement qui seront dans l'économie
si on voit vraiment l'inflation continue
à augmenter on continue à voir
surchauffe mans de l'économie ça se
pourrait qu'on considère ça de l'autre
côté ça pourrait 2,50 différent il ya
différentes façons d'y arriver on va
essayer de juges et à mesure mais on
veut avoir toutes les possibilités là
que les gens comprennent que c'est des
possibilités qui peuvent arriver dès
maintenant des développements
économiques au canada vous avez dit
aujourd'hui dans votre discours que vous
allez présenter en juillet une analyse
des erreurs qu'on a faites dans nos
prévisions d'inflation est-ce que vous
reconnaissez donc que la banque du
canada a fait des erreurs dans son
évaluation de l'inflation on m'a
certainement qu'on reconnaît qu on a
fait des erreurs et vraiment c'était un
temps c'est un temps très difficiles à
prédire l'inflation en grande partie de
l'inflation est dominé par le prix du
pétrole le prix de certains aliments des
prix des commodités c'est tous des
choses très difficiles à prédire et là
ça vraiment ça combiné ensemble mais en
même temps on a assez d'apprendre donc
même déjà on essaye déjà d'apprendre de
nos erreurs mais beaucoup de choses sur
les chaînes d'approvisionnement qu'on
connaissait moins avant cette pandémie
maintenant on les regarde beaucoup plus
en détail comprendre comment que un
problème à un endroit dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement affectent un autre
après un certain temps donc on apprend
ces gens des deux côtés là et c'est ça
qu'on va avoir donné un peu une idée où
sont les erreurs qu'on a fait ou est ce
qu'on pourrait aller pour faire mieux
dans le futur l'inflation a dépassé
systématiquement nos prévisions c'est ce
que vous avez dit aujourd'hui est ce que
ces erreurs même quand même a des
répercussions importantes pour les
familles pour les familles à faibles
revenus pour les pme pour l'économie
canadienne bien il faut bien voir c'est
certainement un juge local par exemple
je prends le prix du pétrole puis à tout
le monde pour acheter de l'essence à la
pompe
ça c'est dit il pour les canadiens mais
il faut bien voir ça c'est pas dit prix
qu'on contrôle directement nous nous ça
c'est des prix internationaux mais c'est
certain que quand les prix dit pas les
gens peuvent pas les à bien se préparer
et ça ça a un effet sur les sur les
canadiens nous qu'est-ce qu'on contrôle
s'est plus la partie de l'inflation qui
est plus de sources domestiques qui
survint à relier plus au chauffe
surchauffe de l'économie et là vous
dites que vous ne voulez pas laisser
l'inflation sans racines et qu'on entre
dans une spirale inflationniste qui
s'autoalimente en quelque sorte est ce
que la banque centrale est responsable
de ce risque d'enracinement de
l'inflation on est responsable de
s'assurer que ça sans racines pas donc
en ce moment à cause de beaucoup d ces
développements internationaux on peut
pas dire que on est complètement
responsable de caisse qui s'est passé
avec les prix beaucoup de ces choses-là
se détermine ce mot codé mondiale mais
qu'est ce qu'on est responsable c'est de
ramener cette inflation à 2% et de pas
laissées sans racines et donc ça c'est
notre mandat et c'est ça qu'on va viser
à contrôler est ce que ce sont vos
erreurs dont vous parlez qui fait en
sorte aujourd'hui qu'on est obligé un
grande vitesse d'essayer d'éviter que
l'inflation sans racines bien je dirais
je le mettrais un peu différemment je
dirais que tous ces changements là du
côté international je prends la guerre
en ukraine par exemple c'était une des
raisons qu'on a manqué nos prévisions
d'inflation et ça c'est à augmenter
beaucoup les prix de beaucoup de
l'inflation était quand même élevé avant
la guerre monsieur beaudry nom était
exactement mais juste que je donne des
exemples louis différents éléments qui
ont affecté comme dernièrement c'est
beaucoup ce que fait que nos prévisions
étaient moins bonnes mais à chaque étape
on a eu ses effets et ce côté leur fait
même chose avec prévu je pense pas qu'on
aurait pu faire grand chose pour
certains de ces prix là la grande partie
ou qu' on était plus surpris peut-être
c'est en fait sur leur rebond la vitesse
d'eurobonds dans l'économie canadienne
qui était plus le côté international ça
c'est vrai qu'on a on a aussi trompé
presque tout le monde que c'est être
prévoir ces prix là se sont trompés
c'est pas c'est pas nous spécialement
c'était vraiment difficile et ça de
l'autre côté on pouvait pas faire grand
chose pour ça le côté conte contrôle
plus c'est le côté de la vitesse de
croissance de l'économie canadienne et
ce rebond là était très important et on
le voit les gens sont sortis dépenses et
c'est là qu'on essaye de contrôler pour
que ça ça crée pas une spirale
inflationniste quels sont les risques de
récession au canada selon vous bien nous
il faudra mener un peu là cette demande
là qui est très forte au canada on
essaie de le faire de façon en douceur
d'assez de ramener l'économie on sait
que les gens
sont dans des situations différentes
mais beaucoup de monde en ce moment
veulent dépenser après le départ une
pandémie veulent sortir on veut un peu
calmé cette surchauffe mans et de le
faire en douceur et on espère qu'on
n'arrivera pas à être à une récession
mais c'est un équilibre difficile c'est
exactement un compromis qu'il faut faire
il faut trouver le bon équilibre entre
les effets on veut que l'inflation
retrouve à 2% et on voudrait que ça se
fasse en douceur ce côté de l'économie
réelle monsieur boudry merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir ça me fait plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit